everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're going to be
going over a cool little trap and i'm
going to name it the Queen Amidala trap
I don't know the official name there may
not even be one so I'm just gonna since
it's from the Queen's Indian defense I'm
gonna just call it the Queen Amidala
trap from Queen from Star Wars so it
starts out with pawn to d4 Knight to f6
simple development move holding on to
these light squares on e4 and d5 pawn to
c4 from white Black's gonna play pawn to
e6 now a lot of times you will see the
knight come to c3 from white but if
those players from white don't want to
get into the nihms Oh defense then they
will play Knight to f3 and this is where
the Queen's Indian defense comes in and
it spawned to b6 here getting ready to
fianchetto the bishop to this b7 square
if it wants to in this variation it's
actually Bishop to a6 as we'll see but
White's going to continue in the main
line with pawn to g3 eventually wanting
to fianchetto is Bishop to g2 here
trying to contest this long light square
diagonal that black wants to put his B
his light square Bishop on b7 and
control here from here bishops going to
come to a6 from black and it's going to
try to attack this white pawn on c4 now
white doesn't have too many good moves
as far as defending this pawn if you do
want to learn about all the variations
as far as White's moves you can
definitely watch the Queen's Indian
defense video but for this trap the the
main line is for white to continue with
pawn to b3 and now our bishops going to
come Bishop to b4 check and so white has
to respond here and there's two moves
that you will see but we are setting a
trap but keep in mind this is the normal
main line for black so even if you do
this and why it doesn't fall into the
trap that's not a problem you will still
be able to continue about your your game
you don't have to
do anything crazy or have some crazy
sacrifice that if it doesn't work it's
going to be very bad for you but just
keep in mind the best move from white is
Bishop to d2 and this is going to
continue on the mainline but a lot of
times you won't see Bishop to d2 a lot
of players really love their bishops a
lot and don't want to trade them off and
so a few times you may come across
Knight to d2 and this is a mistake and
it's a mistake because we can bring our
bishop to c3 attacking this rook on a1
now why it's going to have to play very
carefully if he does not want to hold on
or if he does not want to lose his rook
but a lot of times white will falter and
will lose his rook but you can see here
the best move for white now let's bring
his rook to b1 and now we're going to
bring our bishop back to b7 and we're
down on this
efore squared we'd really like to bring
our bishop to this e4 square and then as
you can tell this rook is completely
trapped here now the only option that
white has to hold on to this rook is to
bring his bishop to g2 we are still
going to bring our bishop to e4 but now
white is going to bring his knight to h4
obviously he needs to protect his bishop
here on g2 or else we could take it and
now we're not going to take this rook on
b1 or else he would just take our work
on a 8 and that's really not that great
of a trade for us he takes our rook we
take his rook but instead here once we
take his bishop on g2 he has to
recapture with his knight on g2 and as
you can see here his knight originally
was on this f3 square and what was this
knight on f3 doing it was protecting the
sinner and
same time it was protecting this pawn on
d4 which in the Queen's Indian defense
for white this is a very very powerful
pawn so we're going to go ahead and take
that pawn on d4 and black is going to
have a very good game now keep in mind
here white only lost this one pond only
because you played perfectly and held on
to this rook a lot of times you will see
white falter and they will lose this
rook here on b1 but if you just look at
this as you can see the Queen's in the
in defense we have yet to lose a piece
except our lights for a bishop here
we're up in material and at the same
time we have taken away the central
focus that white has and the Queen's
ending in defense the white really
focuses on this d4 pawn he hasn't pushed
his EEP on forward and instead he's
really trying to focus on these dark
squares trying to control this he 5 and
this c5 square with his d4 pawn and
that's really what its centralized about
and since we've taken that we've kind of
taken control so this is a way for in
the Queen's Indian defence to kind of
lay a trap in your normal attack and
possibly get this rook on b1 but if
white does play correctly he now has his
knight on g2 which is pretty passive
he's going to have to actually move this
around a couple times for it to be a
little bit more active and at the same
time all of our pieces are playing very
well together we can bring our knight to
c6 very active move here we can start to
push our pawns forward and we're up in
material we're going to have in my
opinion a very easy game going forward
as far as controlling the center of the
board and just having much better active
pieces in the middle so keep in mind
this is a trap to potentially win this
rook on b1 but if white does play
correctly
at the least you'll go up a pawn and
material and have a much much stronger
position and control over the game so
hope you guys enjoyed this video it is a
little bit shorter but I definitely want
to make sure that you're aware of this
nice little trap in the Queen's Indian
defence if you haven't checked out the
website www.videoculinary.com